zach eflin arrived at the ballpark and
his knee was not feeling great went
through some treatments and the knee did
not respond so matt moore who was going
to pitch from the fourth inning on today
anyway
is now going to start tonight all you're
asking for for matt moore keep us in the
game
roller out to shortstop deedy's got it
stumbles just a little bit but gets the
throw over one way
down the right field line slicing away
from harper
and rice makes the sliding grab
what a pick by harper and he hung on to
end the top of the first inning in
philadelphia it's a gaggle of gallons
right-hander zach gallon grew up in new
jersey only 10 miles from this ballpark
and he starts off with a strikeout of
odoodle so back-to-back two-out walks
and now dd gregorius
on the ground to first christian
walker's got it gallon had to work but
he strands two no score after one here's
christian walker grew up in the
philadelphia metro area norristown pa
and walker powered by meatballs knocks
it into centers he won no ounce for josh
rojas
another one up the middle and another
one gets through
they will wave pavon smith walker heads
for third and it's one nothing diamond
bags three straight singles open up the
second
it's this one out to center and dunks it
in front of jankowski walkers home and
it's two-nothing d-bags
off the hands out toward left playable
for herrera
beginning is over
flying ball to center marte got all
turned around and he can't get come up
with it it's going to roll to the wall
jankowski will go to second martay fell
down
and he'll go to third he's held up there
as the throw comes in
he got turned around three different
ways
goes to the curve ball and gets the
strikeout he strands gankowski two one
and two out for rojas
soft ground ball right side segora gets
to it has to hurry the throw does in
time and the inning is over
foul tip carson hangs on and then
strikeout number three for gallon
that one's hit out toward right center
field
pavon smith dives and he can't get it it
rolls under his glove and harper will
get to second base standing with a
two-out double runner in scoring
position for the third consecutive in it
two-nothing arizona in the third the
pitch swing at a miss he strike him out
of the innings over and the phillies
leave a runner at second
finds a gap in left center jankowski has
it on the warning track and ellis is in
its second with a stand-up double drew
is two for two nick has grounded out
struck out 0 for two batting in the
lead-off spot against the left-hander
bad board
ahmed sends one deep to left center
field nick cometh it's gone
four-nothing diamondbacks number four
for nick
well he's in there in the leadoff spot
against the left-hander for a reason
and you just saw why there's a no
doubter to left field well back into the
bleachers two quick outs in the fourth
got that fastball in there and nick
ahmed is under it so gallon threw four
he's throwing a lot of pitches but he
leads it four nothing
there's another base hit for christian
walker christian
is on base for the third time tonight
segura waits on it and throws rojas out
no runs one hit one man left
that is weird wild stuff jankowski
strikes out
the topper over to first gallon is there
and he missed it
and freddie will be safe at first
brings up gene segura
with two outs
fly ball right field pretty well hit
going back on it is paving smith to the
wall gone
a two-run home run for segora
and as lightning flashes off to the
right
a little energy back to the ballpark as
the bills evaded a two-run game
it ends an old for 13 for gene
not only that but you took advantage of
an error made by the pitcher
that gets away from miller varsio
hustles into second he's thinking third
it gets way up the line and dalton is in
there
yeah you really need cover to pick him
up now
cabrera finds a gap and drops it in
there barnes shows home to make it 5-2
and ahmed is in it third rbi four is
drooble
100 and carson knocks it into center
this will get another run in ahmed
scores and it's six to two
[Applause]
swing at a miss it gets away that'll
allow deedy to go to at least second and
that's where he'll stop brad miller's
out because first base was occupied two
outs mccutcheon's coming up
right back at you a strand gregorius at
second base and after six innings the
diamondbacks lead to philly 6-2
walker trying to dunk this one into
short left and it gets in over the head
of gregorius christian walker back in
the old hometown three singles at a base
on balls so far
ground ball back toward the middle dede
will step on the back throw to first
with a little traffic around the bag
good time to get marshall
and there's a line drive base in it to
center field
that's a good sign he's got a couple
hits in his last two at bats
right on the corner with a fastball
caleb smith
brings up bryce harper and strands two
this is the fourth pitcher
that kelly has faced coming into relief
carson turns on a fastball can he keep
it fair
carson kelly's done it again
he homers in his second consecutive game
his assault on left hand pitching
continues
and it's eight to two diamondbacks
backhanded stabbed by rojas can't get
out of his glove they get a runner at
second base and a run scores it's eight
to three
fly ball left center field
marshall was able to roy missed it
it hit off his glove and everybody's
going to be safe
it's a little keystone cop action
and a line drive out to right center
field that'll be an extra base hit going
all the way to the scoreboard two runs
will score and harper pulls into second
base it's his second double of the night
and a live drive base in it to right
field two runs are gonna score it's an
eight to seven game
the tying run is at first base the
winning run is coming to the plate
ball game
phillies sent nine men to the plate in
the ninth inning they got five across
they got the winning run to the plate
but the diamondbacks up eight to two
hang on and win it eight to seven
[Applause]